[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
This is our last quiz
review for the term, quiz 3,
we'll be talking
about, which will be
the last quiz until the final.
It's on dynamic
programming, which
you guys have been studying
in lectures, and recitations,
and on your problem sets 7 and
8, and lectures 15 through 18,
so four lectures.
Quiz 1 and quiz 2 material on,
essentially, data structures
and graph algorithms aren't
going to be explicitly test--
or we're not trying
to explicitly test it,
that material, on quiz 3.
But it is fair game.
The material's cumulative.
And so if you have to store some
stuff in the data structure,
that's fair game.
But we're not
specifically trying
to test you on that material.
OK, and really,
we haven't learned
all that much new material
in these last four lectures
in this unit.
So this is scope.
We've got, we're mostly
handling dynamic programming
on these four lectures and
recitations and these two
problem sets.
But really, the
focus is going to be
on this recursive framework
of solving problems
with a focus on dynamic
programming, specifically.
Now, the recursive
framework we have,
I think, in previous slides,
we used this SRTBOT notation.
And I think there
might be a space there
in previous versions.
I'm concatenating
them together here.
But really, it's a framework
for solving breaking down
your problem into a set of
subproblems that can then
be related recursively.
And if that relationship depends
on problems in a decreasing
or in a smaller sense,
there's a directionality
to which subproblems I'm
reducing to each time I
make a recursive call.
And that dependency
graph is a cyclic.
Then we can solve via
dynamic programming
by memoizing from bottom
up or by calling things
and remembering the
calls that we've
called before via memoization.
And the basic idea here is this
the recursive framework SRT
BOT that we established is good
for any recursive algorithm.
But in the special
case where subproblems
may be used more
than once, may be
used when computing
other subproblems,
then we get this
really nice speed
up by recognizing
that we don't have
to do that work more than once.
And essentially,
instead of looking at it
as a tree of
recursive calls that
may call the same
problems more than once,
we look at it by collapsing
those nodes of the same value
down into one.
We get a DAG.
And dynamic programming is
when those subproblems overlap.
OK, so let's take a look
at our recursive framework
here, SRT BOT.
We have the S-R-T B-O-T. I
remembered the space this time.
Subproblem, you're going
to define some subproblems.
You're going to relate
them recursively.
You're going to specify
a topological order
of those subproblems that
the relation satisfies.
You're going to list some
base cases, basically wherever
you could solve this
problem in constant time
without doing any
recursive work.
Stating how you solve the
original problem, which
might involve combining many
subproblems, but frequently,
is just finding one
subproblem, and possibly
remembering-- storing
parent pointers
to return an optimal sequence,
or something like that.
And then, analyze the time.
Now, the last one isn't really
important for solving a problem
recursively.
But in this class,
it's really important,
because we want to tell whether
the algorithms that we make
are efficient.
So let's dive a little deeper
into each one of these things.
So when we approach
a subproblem,
really, what I'm asking
you for is to describe--
basically, set up
a set of problems.
Basically, I like to
use the variable x.
But you can use whatever
variable you want.
But basically, you're telling
us what's in your memo
and how big your memo is.
So we usually have x as a
function of some variables.
And you're wanting
to describe to me
what the meaning
of that subproblem
is in terms of the parameters.
Now, if you have parameters
in your subproblem
that don't appear in your
subproblem definition,
you're doing it wrong.
And you're probably not going
to get points for the problem.
Because I don't know what
your problem means now.
Even if it's a correct problem
and you do the rest of it
right, part of this class
is about communication.
And if you're not communicating
to us what this thing is doing,
it's really difficult for us--
for you to convince us that
your algorithm is correct.
So you really want
to, in words, describe
what the output of
your subproblem is.
What will the memo return to me?
And how those
return values depend
on the inputs, the parameters
of your subproblem.
So that's what,
in words, describe
what a subproblem means.
So that's going to be a
really important thing for you
not to forget on a quiz.
Then, when making subproblems,
often, what we're doing is
we're rehearsing on different
values of indices in a sequence
or numbers in your problem.
That's kind of what we
got to in the last--
in lecture 18, I
guess, when we were
talking about expanding
subproblems based
on an integer in a problem.
Now actually, an
integer in our problem
is the number of
things in a sequence.
And so, really, those indices
are integers in our problem
that we're looping over.
Except those integers happen to
be the size of our subproblem.
Whereas, other integers
might be larger,
which is why you might get a
pseudopolynomial time bound.
But in general, when I
have a sequence of things
that I might want to
dynamic program over,
common choices for subproblems
are prefixes or suffixes
if I can kind of
locally figure out
to do with one what to do with
one item and then recurse.
Or if I can't kind of localize
it by one choice on one side,
if I have to make a
choice in the middle,
or I have to make a
choice on both ends,
then you might want to use sub--
basically contiguous
subsequences of your sequence.
Because you might
need that flexibility
when reversing
downward, if you need
to take something from both
the front and the back,
for example.
And really, what's
the difference
between prefixes and suffixes?
Not much.
OK, we've been concentrating
on suffixes in this class.
Because in some sense,
it's easier to think about.
What am I doing with the
first thing in my sequence,
or my suffix?
And then I can recurse
on what happens later.
Now, in actuality, when you're
doing this, say, bottom up,
the actual computation
that is evaluated first
is where in that sequence?
I may be calling, at
the top level, what
happens to my first element.
But I'll actually deal with
that first element last.
Because I will recursively
solve everything below me,
in front of me, before I figure
out what to do with this thing.
So in actuality, when
I'm solving my recursion,
I will start at
the end, bottom up,
because that's my base case.
And then I'll work my
way back to the front.
Whereas, with prefixes, you
look at it the other way.
What am I doing with
my last element?
If I look at what I'm
doing at the last element,
I recurse on a prefix, on
the stuff that's before me.
And then when I do bottom
up, I start from the front
and work my way up.
it's two different
sides of the same coin.
And usually, these
are interchangeable.
We've been doing it suffix-wise,
because when starting to learn
dynamic programming,
it's a lot--
we read things from left to
right and things like that.
It's a lot easier
to figure out what's
happening with the first thing
and move forward, conceptually.
It's actually exactly
the same thing.
I could just flip my sequence,
do the exact same thing
with prefixes.
It would be the exact
same dynamic program.
So these things are
interchangeable.
It's really useful, when
learning to dynamic program,
to be able to switch back and
forth between these things.
We'll be working
on suffixes today
on the problems that we do.
But these are interchangeable.
And sometimes it's useful to
be able to conceptually think
about it in both directions.
So aside from dealing with
subsequences of sequences,
in particular,
contiguous ones, we also
often multiply our subsets
across multiple inputs.
Like if we have
multiple sequences,
we might take indices
in each one of them
to represent
prefixes or suffixes.
And then we might have to
remember additional information
by maintaining some
auxiliary information,
like am I trying to maximize
or minimize my sum in a--
or evaluated expression in
an arithmetic parenthization.
Or is it player 1's
turn or player's 2 turn?
Or which finger-- where was
my finger when I was playing
piano or something like that?
Those are the kinds
of things that we
might expand our state on.
And in particular, we
might expand our state
based on the numbers
in our problem
if we're trying to, for
example, keep track of how much
space is left in a knapsack
or something like that.
But in general, if I'm trying
to, say, pack a set of things,
it's useful to know how much
space I have left to pack.
So that's subproblems.
This is really the key part
about dynamic programming
is the recursive part.
This is what makes it hard is
choosing a set of subproblems.
And it's often you
build subproblems
to fit well with relations.
So usually, building what
these subproblems are
is usually closely coupled
with the next step,
which is relating the
subproblems recursively.
And relate recursively, I--
usually what I want
is an expression,
a mathematical
expression, relating
the definition of
a subproblem you
had in the previous section,
relating those, in math terms,
to the other things.
This is-- it's really important
that you write this in math,
because it needs to be precise,
to communicate this thing well.
Now, you can write it in words.
But I would suggest you write
it as a mathematical expression,
because it's a lot
more concise for us
to see what's happening
in your recursion.
So relate them recursively.
Basically, I'm
going to write, say,
that x of some set of parameters
equals some function, usually
a maximization, or a
minimization, or a summation,
or and or, or an and,
or some other combinator
of a bunch of choices
that you might make, so--
or a bunch of subproblems
that you might recurse on.
Basically, you're
going to depend
on some other subproblems that
are smaller in some sense.
Now, actually embedded
in this, the idea
of a smaller subproblem isn't
really well defined yet.
We haven't told you an
ordering of these subproblems
to be smaller.
But that's what's going
to come in the third step.
So kind of a strategy
for figuring out
what these recursive
relations might be
is to identify some question
about the subproblem solution.
What do I do with the first
character in this string?
Or which cage do I
put this tiger in?
To figure out what subproblem
should I recurse on later?
I don't know the answer
to that question.
But if I knew the
answer to that question,
then I could recurse on
a smaller subproblem,
because I figured out what
to do with that tiger.
And so it will let me reduce
to smaller subproblems.
And then, what dynamic
programming does
is because I only have
a polynomial number
of subproblems, and I
assumed I've already
computed what those
are, I've already
memoized what the solutions
to those problems are,
then I can just
locally brute force
over all the possible
answers to that question.
And that's one way to look
at dynamic programming.
OK, so then as we were talking
about topological order,
arguing that
relation is acyclic.
Essentially, just
defining what smaller
means when we say
we're recursing
on smaller subproblems.
What does smaller mean?
Usually, you're
saying that some index
or some parameter
of my subproblem
always decreases or increases.
Sometimes, that's
not always the case.
Sometimes, you have
to, maybe, add a couple
indices and see that
that always increases,
because one may stay the same
while the other increases
or something like that.
But in general, as
long as you argue
that the relations
are acyclic, then
the subproblem graph is a DAG.
And you can compute
in a bottom-up manner.
And you don't get infinite
loops in your recursion.
OK, the last thing, the
last couple of things
are kind of bookkeeping.
But if you don't write
these on your exam,
we can't give you
points for them.
So write these down.
Base cases, if you don't
tell us base cases,
then your algorithm
cannot be polynomial time.
It can't even be finite time,
because your algorithm never
stops.
It just continues to recurse
forever and ever and ever.
And so it's hard
to give us points--
I mean, we will
give you some points
if your subproblems and
relation are correct.
But really, if you write
code without a base case,
it's going to be wrong.
So base cases are
really important.
Basically, for anything at the
bounds of your computation,
wherever your recursive
relation would essentially
go outside the
bounds of your memo,
let's say I'm dealing
with a subsequence.
And at some point, I'm
trying to point to a state
where I have zero
or negative elements
in my sequence, that's
probably a bad thing.
And so I want to
define how to compute
those things in constant time.
So that my algorithm can
terminate when it gets
to one of those base cases.
So it's really
important that you
cover all of those
possible leaf locations
where you want to be able
to return in constant time.
And we'll do some of that today.
State solutions
for all reachable,
independent subproblems where
the relation breaks down.
Essentially, I would be going
outside the bounds of my thing.
Or anything where, maybe if
you've got one item left,
you might say, well,
I have no choice
on what to do with that item.
I have to pick it or
something like that.
OK, then for your
original problem,
you show how to compute
solution to the original problem
from the solutions
of your subproblems.
So usually, this is just
here's a subproblem.
It's the one that used
all of the things,
and that's going
to be my answer.
But that's not always the case.
Sometimes, like in a longest
increasing subsequence,
we had to take a max over all of
our problems that we computed,
or max subarray sum,
we also had to do that.
But in general, the
output to our subproblems
wants to be some scalar value
that we're trying to optimize,
or a Boolean, or
something like that.
It's how we maximize or
minimize what we're doing.
We're not storing the entire
sequence of how we got there.
Because there could be
an exponential number
of possible subsequences
that got there.
That's the whole point
of dynamic programming.
We're kind of isolating the
complexity of one subproblem
down to a single number.
But in a lot of problems, we
might want to reconstruct,
say, the placement of tigers
into cages and not just how--
what's the minimum discomfort
over all tigers or something
like that, like you had
in your problem set.
So I actually want to know
where to put tigers into cages.
And to do that, every time
I maximized a subproblem,
I can remember which subproblem
or subproblems I depended on,
just like storing parent
pointers in shortest paths.
And then, using those
parent pointers,
I can just walk back
in my subproblem graph
and figure out which
path to a base case
led me to an optimal solution.
And then the last thing
is analyzing running time.
Generally, you're
just summing the work
done by each subproblem.
Because the assumption
is you're calculating
all of the subproblems
you described to me.
But if the work per subproblem
is bounded by the same value,
you can just multiply it out.
So that's generally
a weaker bound,
but usually asymptotically
equivalent to the stronger
notion on the left.
And that's basically
how you do running time.
Usually, it's enough to--
how do I determine how
many subproblems I have?
Well, I look at
the possible values
of each of my parameters.
And then I multiply
those numbers together.
A lot of people will maybe
say, oh, I add them together.
No, because I'm able to choose
each of these independently.
And so I multiply
those things together.
And then the work done
by each subproblem
is usually the
size of the thing I
maximizing over,
or minimizing over,
or summing in my relation.
It's going to be the size
of that, the branching
that I have, the number of
subproblems I depend on.
And so the number
of subproblems,
you probably look at
your subproblem statement
definition.
To find the work done
by each subproblem,
you look at your
recursive relation.
OK, so with that, we've got
this really nice framework.
And we're going to use
it to solve some practice
problems, happy days.
And these are a little bit
longer in terms of description
than our previous quiz 2 review.
So I'm going to go ahead
and read them out for you.
This one's a little shorter.
Tiffany Bannen stumbles upon a
lottery chart dropped by a time
traveler from the future,
which lists winning lottery
numbers and positive integer
cash payouts for the next n
days.
Anyone get the reference
here, Tiffany Bannen?
Biff Tannen from some
Back to the Future thing.
So this was actually--
I think it's the second to
Back to the Future movie
where this happens.
Anyway, Tiffany wants to use
this information to make money,
because she knows the
future about the lottery.
But is worried that if she
plays winning numbers every day,
lottery organizers will get
suspicious and shut her down.
So the idea here is maybe it's
still suspicious, but decides
to play the lottery
infrequently, at most,
twice in any seven day period.
She'll win, but it's
infrequent enough
that maybe that's by
chance, maybe not.
Describe a linear-time algorithm
to determine the maximum amount
of lottery winnings
Tiff, Tiffany,
can win in the next 10
days by playing the lottery
infrequently.
Now, this was a particularly
difficult type of p-set,
or first p-set on dynamic
programming problem.
But let's try to do it together.
So this is problem 1.
I'm going to just call it Lotto.
OK, so how can we deal
with subproblems here?
Well, I might want
to think about what
do I do on the first day.
Am I going to play
the lottery or not?
And then recurse on the rest.
That sounds good, right?
I might have something like--
well, let's say that L of
i is the winnings on day i.
This is kind of just like--
this doesn't define use notation
on what the cash payouts are.
And so I'm making a
variable to do that.
And for the sake of what's
written down on my sheet,
I'm going to assume that this
is 1 index, I don't know why.
So I have days 1 to n.
I know what their
lottery payouts are.
So I might, when I'm
doing my SRT BOT stuff,
I have subproblems.
What I might want to do is
see what happens on day one
and recurse on what's later.
So I might have
something like x of i
is max winnings for, I guess,
possible for days i to n.
Anyone have a problem with
this type of subproblem?
Let's kind of see what this type
of subproblem would lead me to.
I can either, in my relate
step, what are my choices?
I can either play on day i
or I cannot play on day i.
If I'm trying to maximize
this thing, maximize.
Either if I play
on day i I get Li.
And then I can recurse
on the remainder.
Or I don't plan Li and I
recurse on the remainder.
Anyone like this recurrence?
Why don't we like
this recurrence?
I'm just always going
to pick this thing.
These things are
always positive.
I think it's always positive
integer payouts, yeah.
And so I'm always
going to pick Li
and the problem
here is this is not
obeying or dealing with
this condition that I have,
which is I'm only allowed to
play twice a week, or not quite
twice a week.
It's not a fixed
week-long period.
It's within any consecutive
seven-day period,
which is a little confusing.
How can I remember what days
I'm allowed to pick later on?
It seems a little daunting.
In a sense, for me to know--
this is max winning
possible for days i to n.
But in some sense, it depends
on which days I picked before.
Because if I picked i minus
1, I can't pick another day
for another six days.
If I have-- right, so I have--
let's do this precisely.
This is i minus 1.
I have seven day period,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
If I played the lottery here
and I played the lottery here,
then I'm not allowed to
play the lottery here,
I'm not allowed to play here,
not allowed to play here,
not allowed to play here.
I am allowed to play here.
So this is i plus 1, plus
2, plus 3, plus 4, plus 5,
plus 6, i plus 6.
So depending on what
happened before me,
I might not be able to
play until day i plus 6.
But if I haven't played until--
since way back here, I could
potentially play the next guy.
I don't actually know which
of these I can play on next.
In some sense, I need to
remember which days I'm
allowed to play on next.
And I want to be able to--
at the beginning, I
have no restrictions.
I can just play on this guy
next, even if I played there.
But in general, I
will be restricted
in some way between being
able to play on this guy
and being able to
play on this guy.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to generalize
my problems by storing
additional information so that
I can rely on that information
when I look into the
future and recurse.
So instead of--
I'm going to, in some sense,
need to remember two days.
Where was the last
two places I played?
I'm going to simplify that
a little bit by saying
that this subproblem, max
winnings possible for days
i to n, I'm going to say
that I have to play on day i,
similar restriction as longest
increasing subsequence,
I'm definitely including
this in my subsequence.
That's just going to make
it easier for me to be like,
oh, I definitely know
I played on this day.
It's going to be-- it would
make it easier for my thinking.
So assuming play on
day i, and actually, I
need to remember what's
the next day I can play.
So I'm going to expand this
subproblem by another--
I guess this is a j.
OK, assuming I play on day
i, and I'm allowed to play,
I guess, and next allowable
play on day i plus j for,
what are my possible
range of days for j?
I can either play the
next day, but I'm never
restricted past day i plus 6.
Because the things
before me [AUDIO OUT]
further to the right, because
I haven't dealt with them yet.
So I only have to deal
with this from 1 to 6.
Well, this is nice, because
it expanded my subproblems
by a constant number.
So I actually didn't lose
anything asymptotically here
by remembering this information.
But I'm kind of--
I'm able to remember
all the things that
could have happened before me.
I compress it into
this one number.
OK so now let's
rewrite our relation.
I'm actually going to go
ahead and use some more board
space, because I think
that's easier than erasing.
All right, so we are
looking at my relation.
This is a pretty
complicated relation.
But what's happening now?
Now, I'm assuming
I play on day i.
That actually simplifies
things a little bit.
Because no matter what, I
get the winnings on day i.
Now, when I call
this subproblem,
I better make sure that it's
OK that I played on day i.
But that's in my caller.
I am locally allowed
to play on day i.
I am playing on day i.
That's the definition
of my subproblem.
x of i is I'm going to
maximize over some choice.
Max of-- I guess I
have Li no matter what.
So this could actually
come out of my max.
And then I'm going to choose--
what am I choosing here?
I'm not choosing whether
I'm playing on day i.
I'm choosing what my next
day i play is, so that then I
can recurse on that subproblem.
So what day can I play on?
Well, I'm kind of restricted
by this j parameter
that I didn't add into
my subproblem on what
possible days I can play next.
I'm going to split that into--
kind of compress
that into one thing.
So x, I can play on--
I have a choice of
the next day I play,
somewhere between j, which
is my next allowable play,
and sometime in the future.
So i plus k, this is going to
be my loop that I'm looping over
in terms of my max.
And then, what am I
restricted on in my play?
It depends on how
far I am from i.
So if I'm here, this is i.
If I choose k to
be the next day,
I can't play for
many, many times.
So the subproblem I'm
going to recurse on is--
this is i plus k.
I'm going to
recurse on i plus k.
But I'm not able to--
j needs to be the max it can be.
Because I can't
play until i plus 6.
So this i plus k plus 6
is going to be my thing.
So let's see.
So I'm going to put--
let's see if I can unpack
what I wrote down here.
Max of 1, 7 minus k.
Yuck.
Oh, I'll put it here.
1, 7 minus k.
OK, if I pick k, I'm not
aggressive toward these boards
as Justin is.
So if I pick a k way down here,
I'm not restricted at all.
And so the most permissive
option I have here is 1.
So I definitely can't
be worse than 1.
But if I pick--
and then this needs to be
some number between 6 and 1.
And so I can just
check the other bound.
If this is the most productive,
then this should be 6.
So when k equals 1,
this should be 6.
And it decreases every
time further back--
or further forward
I choose this k.
So that's what my
subproblem is going to be.
And I'm choosing over k in--
from j, sorry i plus j, sorry,
j, thank you, until what?
That's the question, until what?
Do I have to loop over n?
If I loop over n,
I'm going to get
a quadratic running
time, which is worse
than what I'm allowed to do.
The assumption is that
I only have to check
the constant number of these.
And why might that be?
Any ideas?
Let's say I am--
got my subproblem,
I'm recursing.
I've got i.
Yeah, I don't know where j is.
j is somewhere over here, One,
two, three, maybe it's four,
or something like that.
Let's say I pick
some k down here.
What is this?
This is i plus--
so this is j is 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 15,
way over here, two weeks later.
Is it ever optimal
for me to do that?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: You could play
the lotto in the middle
and it wouldn't effect it.
JASON KU: Yeah, I could
play the lotto in the middle
here, right?
Within-- from here
to there, that's
a seven day period where
I only played once.
And from here to here,
that's a seven day period
where I only played once.
So it's going to be--
these are positive values.
So it's going to be more optimal
for me to choose something
in here to play.
So how far--
I mean, I could just use
15 and that would satisfy.
Because I've already argued to
you that it's never optimal to.
I can check this.
It's not going to be optimal.
It's going to be more optimal
to play some time over here.
But how far do I have to check?
Well, maybe I have
to check up to 7.
Does that work?
Not quite.
So let's say I played
here, and I played here,
and I played here,
I actually can't play here,
here, here, here, here.
I'm not allowed to play those.
I guess these should be O's.
I played there.
And I'm not allowed to
play here, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
But I am allowed to
play anywhere in here.
So I basically
want to shrink this
until these X's collide
with each other.
Because then it's possible
that an optimal solution
would require me
to pick these two
and then require me to pick
these two way over there.
So this is 10 things
in the middle.
I only have to go
up to, at most, 11.
It's 11.
Now, you can move
any constant above 11
and get the same
running time bound.
But that's my analysis.
OK, so we have our
recursive relation.
And so what am I doing?
I'm just looping over my
choices of next day to play.
I'm rehearsing on this
thing where I actually
do play on that day.
But I'm remembering
the information
about what I'm allowed
to play next by limiting,
based on what my
previous value was.
So that's the kind of key thing.
I'm remembering something
further in advance--
or I'm remembering what
happened in the past
by describing it as a
restriction of something
in the future.
So this was a pretty
difficult problem.
I think it was one of our first
dynamic programming problems
on that term.
It was probably a
little ambitious.
AUDIENCE: Are you saying this
recurrence goes up to 11?
JASON KU: Yes, the recurrence
goes up to 11, not 10, 11.
So we have our topological sort.
What's a topological thought
for these subproblems?
Anybody?
k is always going to
be a positive number.
Because j goes from 1 to 6.
So I'm always going
to be increasing
in this first quantity.
So for x of i, j, i always--
sorry, depends on
strictly larger i.
So this i, when I
call subproblems,
it always calls subproblems
with a larger i.
Now, this is a little
weird, because I
wanted me to depend on
smaller subproblems, smaller.
Now, it is smaller, because
I'm taking a smaller suffix.
But its corresponding to
using a larger number.
To me, that's a little
confusing, but that's OK.
Because we're kind
of using things
that are always monotonically
going in some direction.
So this is corresponding
to a smaller subproblem
in some measure.
It's the number of elements that
we're actually recursing on.
In some sense, if we
wrote this as a prefix,
we would have us depending
on strictly smaller i.
And that would be more
natural in terms of recursing
on smaller subproblems.
But I digress.
All right, then we have
our original subproblem.
I'm going to--
I can't move this board.
I'll just keep going, because
we have lots of boards.
OK, our original subproblem,
now, what could I do?
I have to start somewhere.
Here, my subproblem's assuming
that I'm starting at i.
But I don't know where I start.
I could start by taking the
first element, but I might not.
So I could just take
the max over all i,
over all i of x what?
The first one,
I'm not restricted
on what I choose next.
So what's the most
permissive version of j?
One, I'm allowed
to take the next j.
So if I just take the max
over all of these subproblems,
I'll get the solution.
Now, actually, this is a little
bit more work than I need.
This is looping over all n.
It's definitely correct, because
I have to start somewhere.
But will I ever start after
the first, I don't know, 7?
No, so I could
just take this max
over the first some
constant number.
And that would be fine.
But that's OK.
This is still smaller than
the number of subproblems
that we have.
AUDIENCE: If I were
being lazy during my exam
and I looped over j,
would that be correct?
JASON KU: If I
looped over j for?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
over every possible thing.
JASON KU: Took the
loop over this and j?
Yeah, that would still be fine.
Why not?
It's just less-- it's more
restrictive of subproblems.
It will never be
better to do that.
But you could do that, because
it wouldn't change your running
time.
AUDIENCE: Could it
change my running time
if my j accidentally
looped too far?
JASON KU: Well, j is
restricted to be 1 to 6.
So I'm not--
I don't think so.
But in a different problem, in
a different context, it could.
OK, so that's the original.
And in time here,
what do we got?
We have a linear
number of subproblems,
number of subproblems.
We've got-- I actually like,
usually, saying exactly how
many subproblems I have.
Oh, we didn't do base case.
I missed BOT, I missed my B.
We'll do the original first.
And then the base case.
OK, base case, what do we
have as a base case here?
Well, when I don't
have anything to do.
If I'm-- and actually, if I have
this situation for i equals,
say, n, I got my last thing.
I could potentially
start looping over
sbuproblems that are negative
in terms of my index.
I'm not going to
want to do that.
There's a couple of ways
I can deal with that.
I could set a value for all
of my problems for negative i.
That's one thing I could do.
But then I have to
kind of remember,
or I have to figure out how
far I go into the negative.
That's one thing I could do.
And I give a base case
for each of those cases.
I don't have anything.
So I get a--
I don't know, zero value
for playing in the future,
because I have negative things.
I can't do anything with that.
Another way of
handling that, which
I think I did in
my solutions, was
restrict that k to only be--
I guess and restrict that i plus
k is less than or equal to n.
And then, I'll never go
to negative problems.
I'll never recurse
on these things.
But that means that
when I call this
on n, When I only have
one lottery day left,
this set will be empty.
So what's the max
over that thing?
Max over an empty set?
I don't know.
I mean, I could add on 0 here,
that's one way I could do it.
Or I could just say when I'm
at n, and that thing is empty,
or whenever it's empty,
we can say the base case
x i, j, I guess we could put
this at n equals 0, or sorry,
equals L of i, L
of n, thank you.
Because at the last
guy, I have to use Ln.
So there it is.
Now, in actuality, if
you write this correctly,
I put the Li outside, and
I union this with the 0,
I can actually get
away with just having
the relation and no base case.
Because my relation actually
reduces to a base case,
because of the way that
I wrote my relation.
But in general, you'll want to
write some kind of base case
here to either acknowledge
that your relation handles it
or be specific
about what happens
when I can't do any more work.
And the last thing, time,
we've got n subproblems exactly
times constant work
per subproblem.
Because I'm looping
over 11 possible values,
actually, it's up to 11,
because j could be 6.
So this is order n work total.
So this is a pretty
daunting first problem.
But in terms of what
Erik, Professor Demaine,
was talking about last lecture,
in terms of categorization
of subproblem, or categorization
of dynamic programs, what do
we got?
We've got a suffix
subproblem where
we expanded by some
local information,
remembering when the
next time I can play.
So that's kind of
a categorization
of these subproblems.
The recurrence relation
has constant branching,
but more than two branching.
And I'm combining a
bunch of subproblems
in my original evaluation.
And if I wanted to figure out
what days Tiff should play
on the lottery, you can
store parent pointers
when I'm evaluating this max.
I figure out which
subproblem x I recurse--
that gave me the max.
And I can walk back
to see which choices
I made to figure out which
days I played the lottery.
Does that make sense?
So any questions on problem 1?
That's the most--
I wanted to have the most
complicated one first.
So that we could have
an easier way to go.
In a sense, this is the
most complicated version
of this kind of actually pretty
simple dynamic programming
setup.
Why do I say simple
dynamic programming setup?
It's just suffixes.
And I'm just doing a constant
amount of work local to me.
It's just a very
complicated local setup.
But that's what
I mean by simple.
When we're designing
subproblems,
this is one that we could--
I mean, when we're
designing problems
for this dynamic
programming setup,
it's one of the hardest from a--
it's one of the easiest from
a conceptual standpoint,
but one of the hardest
to actually implement.
OK, so problem 2,
this one's a long one.
A wealthy family, Alice, Bob,
and their young son Charlie
are sailing around the world.
When they encounter
a massive storm,
Charlie is thrown
overboard, presumed drowned.
This is very colorful language
for these problem set writers.
20 years later, a man
comes to Alice and Bob,
claiming to be Charlie,
having maybe been marooned
on an island for that long.
Alice and Bob are
excited but skeptical.
And they order a matching
tests from the genetic testing
company 46 and Thee.
Given Alice and Bob--
sorry, given three length
n DNA sequences, basically
strings of CGTA, or
something like that,
from each of Alice,
Bob, and Charlie,
the testing center
will determine three--
their ancestry as follows.
If Charlie's can be
partitioned into two,
not necessarily contiguous,
subsequences of equal length,
so basically I can take--
if I have n is length 5 or
length 6, it's better be even.
I need to find three
characters in order.
And then the other
three characters
must match to make
some substrings--
some subsequences in
Alice and Bob's DNA.
So that's a little
hard to parse.
So let's look at
an example here.
For Example.
Alice's is AATT.
Bob's DNA is CCGG.
If Charlie's were
CATG, they'd be
matched, because CG is a
subsequence of Charlie's DNA,
and is a subsequence
of Bob's DNA.
And AT is a subsequence
of Charlie's DNA.
And Is also a subsequence
of Alice's DNA.
And so we've partitioned
them into two equal length
subsequences.
These are not necessarily
consecutive subsequences,
but just any subsequences,
such that they
appear in Alice and Bob.
But if Charlie would be found to
be an impostor, if his sequence
were AGTC, essentially,
it's easy to realize that,
because G and C are swapped
in terms of their ordering.
And GC, the letters GC
only appear in Bob's DNA
and don't appear in that order.
So it's easy to see that he's
an imposter with these strings.
But you can imagine,
with longer strings,
this could be
difficult to solve.
So we want an n to
the 4th time algorithm
to determine whether
Charlie is a fraud.
OK, so I actually
shortened this last night.
This was twice as long
on the problem set.
So yeah, anyway, so how do
we approach this problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: No, they don't
have to be contiguous.
Like in the example,
it would be matched
if C and G is a subsequence,
not contiguous, of CATG.
Yeah, so that's an important
part of this problem.
I'm just-- I'm not trying
to figure out if there's--
basically, there are only
two contiguous subsequences
of length 2n that this
thing can be partitioned in.
I just look in the middle.
No, we're looking for
subsequences, not substrings.
So they kind of interleave
like this in some way.
And there's actually a
number of different ways
I can partition that.
There's actually an
exponential number of ways.
So that's a problem,
potentially.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a biological basis?
JASON KU: No, there's no
biological basis to this thing
that I know of.
OK, all right, so how do
we solve this problem?
What problem does
this look like?
I mean, it seems
like string matching.
So I might want to think
it's something like longest
common subsequence.
But here, I have three sequences
instead of two sequences.
And we've got this other weird
condition where we kind of need
an exact partition of Charlie.
I need to use all of
the letters in Charlie,
but I don't have to use all of
the letters in Alice and Bob.
So let's get some notation
here A, B, and C are n length
strings.
So what could I do?
Let's define some subproblems.
If I were to go via
longest common subsequence,
I might keep track of an
index of a suffix or prefix
of each one of these strings.
That kind of makes sense.
Something like i,
j, k, where we're
talking about the suffixes--
sorry, that's prefixes,
i, B, j, and C, k.
That seems reasonable, at least.
It's what we would do for
longest common subsequence.
What's the problem here?
I mean, I could match this
guy with one of these guys,
or decide to skip it, and
match one of these guys,
and decide to skip it.
But if I do that, I
might get a subsequence.
But actually, I
always need to match
all of C. Does that make sense?
I always need to match all of C.
So in a sense--
Let's see, how can I do this?
I need to match all
of C. But I also
need to make sure I'm using
exactly n over 2 characters
from C in B. And exactly n
over 2 characters from C in A?
Does that make sense?
So how can I satisfy
that condition?
Now I understand why I
used prefixes before.
And I swapped it
to suffixes here.
But we'll make it work.
How can I remember
how many characters I
assigned from Alice versus Bob?
As I I'm matching
characters in Alice and Bob,
I need to kind of remember
where they point to,
or how many I've
already used in Charlie.
So that I can divvy up
the remainder in here.
Oh, actually, this works
in a different sense.
There's 18 different
ways we could do this.
So, OK, so I need to remember
how many I've already used up,
so that I can be
sure to allocate
exactly that many
characters in the future
to either Alice or Bob.
So how can I remember that?
I can just remember.
How many do I--
I'll do it the way
that I did it before,
which is I can remember--
I can remember two
different things here.
I can remember how many things I
have left to match Alice, in C,
or I can remember how
many things I've already
matched in C to Alice.
If I talk about how many
things I've already matched,
then I can index this thing
by the sum of those things.
If I talk about how many
things I have yet to match,
I have to do n minus the things.
So those are the different
parameters that we can do.
We'll do what's in my notes.
And I'll try to fix it.
So what we're going to do
is remember-- or figure out
how many things
I'm still needing
to match in C to Alice and Bob.
So I'm going to call this k--
sorry, ki.
i is associated with A.
And B is associated with j.
And kj, this is
going to be the--
I have to write this down.
So this is going to
be what kind of output
do I want to my subproblem?
I just want to know if these
things are-- if he's a fraud
or not.
So this is going
to be a Boolean.
So true if can match ki length
subsequence of suffix A,
suffix is this
guy, and length kj,
I guess, kj length subsequence
of suffix B, ji, or Bj suffix,
to all characters in.
And now what is this in?
This is the hard part.
Do I need a separate index
for C to know where I am in C?
In a sense, yes, I
need to know where I am
in C, how much I have to match.
But if I need to match
ki to kj to all of them,
then there better be ki
plus j things left in C.
So in a sense, I don't need
to remember that information
again.
It's not independent
to my other parameters.
I can compute it.
I could throw it in,
but I can determine it
from the other parameters.
And so I want to match
it with the suffix
of C of length ki plus kj.
So I think this is
the only part that
is going to be annoying to me.
So this should be suffix
of all of the things
minus ki minus kj minus 1.
It's just this.
And why is that?
If I have matched to everything,
ki and kj are both 0.
And I should have nothing
in C, which should n colon.
We're at 0 index, yes we are.
Whenever I use Python notation,
I'd better be 0 index.
Does this make sense
as a subproblem?
I mean, it's confusing.
But hopefully, it makes sense.
What I'm going to
try to do is I'm
going to match some
number of characters
in this suffix, which is
hopefully longer than ki.
Otherwise, it's-- I'm going to
be in a base case where this is
impossible.
And some subsequence of this
matched completely into this.
So that's-- those
are my subproblems.
I'm going to try
to relate them now.
We have x, i, j, ki, kj,
what is this going to equal?
Well, we've got Booleans.
So this is and false otherwise.
That's a Boolean.
So I just need some subproblem
I recurse on to be true.
So what's the
commutator for some
of a bunch of choices, Boolean
choices, any one of which
may be true?
I want to combine
a bunch of them.
I just want to see if
any of them are true.
I'm going to or over them.
I'm going to or
over four choices.
What are my choices?
Either the first thing
in A matches with C,
the first thing in
B matches with C,
or I don't match with either.
So those are my four choices.
So if I match with
A, i plus 1, I
recurse on a smaller
suffix of A and a--
by adding-- oh, this
all just works, great.
Kj, this is i, if Ai equals
Ci and Ai is greater than 0.
So if ki is greater than
0, I need to match an i.
So this conditional
doesn't even make sense
unless I've evaluated this
ki to be bigger than 0.
Otherwise, I'm trying
to access i of n.
So I'm just putting this
conditional on there.
Same with matching B, ij
plus 1, ki, kj, plus 1 if--
sorry, this should be minus 1.
I have fewer characters
that I have to recurse on.
So that's a typo in my notes.
Bj equals C. Oh, this is not Ci.
What is this?
It's whatever that thing is.
So I'm going to just
say question mark
and kj is greater than 0.
So I'll fill that
in in the notes.
It's going to be some
complicated expression that
looks like that.
It's exactly that expression.
Yes, that it is.
So it's that thing.
OK, then we have
two more choices.
Either I-- if I didn't match Ai,
I may match Bj in the future.
So I only want to reduce Ai.
So xi plus 1, I leave
everything else the same.
Assuming if i less
than n, I don't
want to move off the end of
this thing, or x, i, j plus 1,
ki, kj if j is less than n.
So those are my four choices.
If I match the letter n, great.
Otherwise, I decrease the size
of my subproblem and I recurse.
So fun recursion,
topological sort,
these subproblems
only depend on what?
Larger i?
Not quite.
Larger j?
Changing k or-- these
don't even change here.
So we're going to use depend
on larger, I guess, strictly--
that's kind of an
important thing, i plus j.
Because at least one of these
two things is increasing.
And then the nice
thing about that is it
kind of tells us
when we should stop.
We should stop when
either i or j get to n.
We should know
enough, at that point,
to be able to determine if we
succeeded or not, possibly.
So we have our base case.
What's the easy base case?
When we succeeded.
When have we succeeded?
If we have nothing
left in A and B
And we have nothing left in C.
I have nothing left to match.
So I have nn.
And I don't need a
match anything else.
That's just going to be true.
All roads point
to this subproblem
to get to a true solution.
Otherwise, we have
some false base cases.
If you set something
up like this
and you only give us a
base case that's true,
and you're oring
over the things,
your answer will always be true.
So you're not having any
discriminatory power at all.
If you give us a true
base case, you better
be giving us some false base
cases, or one, at least.
So in the case where
the first one is n
And we have some i, kj, this
is going to be false if what?
If we have nothing left in Ai
or A, but this guy is positive,
we got problems.
Otherwise, this thing is 0.
And we'll just try to
match everything up here.
And eventually, we'll get down
to this base case or something
where this thing goes to
0 and we've got a problem.
And the same goes for
the other side as well.
If we run out of things in
B, when the number of things
we need to match in
B is greater than 0.
So those are our base cases.
The original problem is what?
Yeah, it's just going to
be one of our subproblems,
nn, and then n over
2 and n over 2,
trying to match half
of the things in C
with half of the things.
AUDIENCE: The first two
arguments should be 0.
JASON KU: 0, thank you,
because we're 0 index, yes.
Again, that's-- switching from
prefix to suffix in the middle
is fun.
And it better be the
case that n is 2,
or else it's obviously
false-- or is even,
or else this is obviously false.
And then, the last thing, which
I'm not going to write down,
is we have a constant work here.
Because I'm just checking
the value of four
subproblems and a
conditional for each.
And I have how many subproblems?
i loops over n, j loops over
n, k and kj loop over n over 2.
So I get a quartic
number of subproblems,
quartic running
time as designed.
So I'm not going to write that
down, because I'm quite a bit
late.
I'm probably going
to do-- just do one
more problem, which is sad,
because the last one is
about Gokemon Po, which
is fun, fun problem.
Gokemon Po basically
relies on I'm
trying to catch a bunch of
pocket monsters, just monsters,
I think is in this.
And you can either
go to a location
and catch that monster for
free, but that costs money,
because I have to
ride share there.
Or I don't have to
go to that location,
and I buy it on my
in-app purchase,
but that costs me a
different amount of money.
But buying it from
the in-app purchase
kept me at the location I was
previously, wherever I was.
And so the point
of that problem is
I need to remember
where I was last.
So that I know how
far I need to travel
to get to my next monster.
So that's going to be
the last one that I'm not
going to be able to get to.
Number 3 is a
problem about tapas.
So these all come
from spring '18.
The first two came
from a problem set.
These next two come from
the final exam that year.
Obert Ratkins is on a diet.
But he has a dinner
at an upscale tapas
bar, where he got
many-- he's going
to order many small plates.
There are n plates of food on
the menu, where each plate has
a certain information, it
has a volume, the number
of calories in that dish.
And a sweetness label,
basically 0 or 1,
whether it's sweet or not.
But he's on a diet.
And he wants to eat no more
than k calories during his meal,
but wants to fill his
stomach as much as possible,
because he wants to feel full.
So he wants to maximize
the volume that he fills,
even though he wants to reduce
the number of calories--
restrict the number of calories.
He also wants to order
exactly s sweet plates.
So we've got this
other condition
where I need to make sure
I'm eating a certain number
of sweet plates.
It might be useful for me
to remember how many sweet
plates I've already eaten.
So I make sure that
I eat that number,
without purchasing
the same dish twice.
So here's a condition that's
similar to the knapsack 01
problem, versus a knapsack
kind of general problem.
Am I allowed to take more than
one of these things or not?
Here, it's a restriction
that I'm not allowed
to take a plate more than once.
And I'm going to try to
describe an order nks time
algorithm to find the
maximum volume of food Obert
can eat given his diet.
So first thing I'm going to
note here is one of the things
that we talked about at the last
dynamic programming lecture was
is this a polynomial running
time that it's asking me for.
Actually, on your problem set 8,
you were asked on each problem
to categorize whether the
running time of your algorithm
was polynomial or not.
And actually, you don't have
to solve the problem in order
to answer that question if
we give you the running time.
If we give you the
running time, you
can just take a look at that
running time and be like, oh,
is that polynomial and
the size of my input.
And here is it?
All the ones previously were.
This one was order n.
That was order n squared,
because the n was
the number of things in my
input, the number of words
it took to give you that input.
Here, what do I have?
I have a triple of
numbers for each plate.
There are n of them.
So n is polynomial.
s polynomial because
s is smaller than n
and it's positive number.
But k, k is just some
number in my input.
It's representable in,
potentially, one word, that's
the assumption.
But it could have
exponential size
depending on the size of
my word of my machine.
I don't know how big
k is relative to n.
And so this is a
pseudopolynomial running time.
Because k is just a number in my
problem, similar to subset sum,
similar to knapsack,
which you guys
did in lecture and recitation.
And so if we ask you on an
exam, which we probably will,
whether certain running
times are polynomial or not,
that's the logic
that you go about it.
How big is my input?
What is my running time
that I'm trying to evaluate?
And can I bound
each of those terms
in terms of the
size of my input?
If not, then you say
it's pseudopolynomial.
All right, so let's try
to tackle this problem.
Already, because we've
got pseudopolynomial,
you're thinking
maybe this is going
to be knapsack-like
or subset sum-like.
What do I need to--
I'm just going to go straight
for subproblems here.
Actually, I should probably
say what my things are.
Meh, this is fine.
I gave notation up
there, didn't I?
So we're going to
have subproblems.
I'm going to-- I
want to maximize
the number, the volume of food.
So that should
probably be the output
of my subproblem, the max
volume on some subset of dishes.
I'm going to choose
suffixes here.
i and some other stuff is
going to be max volume of food
possible for plates Pi to Pn.
Going to assume one index
here, because why not?
But do I need to remember
information along the way?
Yeah, just like with subset
sum or knapsack, I need--
I have this calorie limit.
So it's going to
be really useful
for me to know how many
calories I've already eaten,
or how many calories I
have left in my budget.
So let's say j, using
at most j calories
from the remaining dishes.
And I need to make sure that
I'm eating exactly some number
of sweet plates in the future.
And I need to remember,
as I eat a sweet plate,
the number of sweet plates
I need to eat decreases.
And so I want to
generalize that.
I'm going to put an s prime
here to denote eating exactly
s sweet plates.
OK, so that's my subproblem.
I've got tons of board space.
I'm going to go
ahead and use it.
Relation, we've got x,
i, j, s prime equals--
OK, I'm trying to
maximize volume.
Probably, I want to be
maximizing over something.
This combinator is kind
of what I like to call it.
Usually, what you're doing
in dynamic programming
is making some kind
of choice or combin--
combining,
combinating, combining
some number of subproblems and
choosing which one's the best.
If you just list a
bunch of options here
and don't tell us
how to combine them,
that's going to be a problem.
Because we don't know
what your dynamic program
is doing at all.
So it's really useful for
you to be able to tell us
how you're combining
your subproblems.
Here, we're doing a maximization
over the different volumes
possible.
If we decide to eat the plate
i, then we get Vi in volume,
we fill our tummies
with Vi in volume.
But then we have to recurse
on using one fewer plate,
because we can't use
that plate again.
And we've decreased the amount
of calories in our budget.
And I'm going to
say s prime minus
si, because si is 1 if it's
sweet and 0 if it's not.
So it's kind of nice
that they kind of
gave us this notation here.
I can just subtract
it off if it's there.
I don't have to do this
conditional or something.
And I don't ever want to
go below these budgets.
So I'm just going
to say if Ci is
less than or equal to
j and si is less than
or equal to s prime.
So that's going to
make sure that I never
have these guys go negative.
Otherwise, I don't
eat the plate.
And that's kind
of the easy case,
because I just go i
plus 1, j, s prime.
These things didn't change.
I just have one
fewer thing left.
So I'm maximizing
over these things.
This one's an always.
It's not an if.
So I just have two choices.
And maximizing over them,
topological sort order,
here, I'm always recursing
on a thing with larger i.
Depend on larger i,
so acyclicl, happy.
Base cases, what's
the good case?
I get to the end, I've
reached the end of my menu,
I can't look at any more
plates, I'm stuffed.
And I've already
forbidden myself
from going negative
on the calories.
So that should be all good.
But what do I want on
the third parameter?
0, I better have eaten
exactly s plates.
So I want to get
down to x n plus 1,
because I'm 1 index,
j, for any j, 0.
That's going to be 0.
I got no calories there.
But it's a good thing.
It's a good place.
It's fine.
0 is good.
This is done, I don't know.
OK, there's another base case.
What's the bad base case.
I get to the end.
I'm always increasing i.
And so I better be doing
something on n plus 1.
I got to the end.
j again, is going
to be non-negative.
Because we're always going
to be in our calorie budget.
But if this is anything other
than s prime greater than--
if it's anything but 0,
what is that going to be?
AUDIENCE: It'd be
minus infinity.
JASON KU: Minus infinity.
I never want to be
in this situation.
If I do my dynamic program
and I get a minus infinity up
at the top, that means there
is no path to this subproblem
here, where I'm happy.
I'm always sad.
And so I return that the
maximum volume of food Obert
can eat and maintain his
diet is not possible.
Essentially, there aren't
s dishes, sweet dishes
in the thing whose calorie
budget are below my limit.
And that's probably
an easier thing
to check than in this band.
So we have our original
subproblems now.
Solution is given by what?
Just one of our
subproblems, it's
just seeing what's
the maximum volume.
I don't have to retrace my
steps to figure out my thing.
I just-- I say one
of the subproblems,
it's using all of the
things on my menu,
using my entire budget k, and
trying to get exactly s things.
That's going to be my
output to my algorithm.
And this takes what time?
How many subproblems do I have?
I have n plus 1 subproblems
for this parameter.
I have k plus 1 possible
things for this parameter.
And I have s plus 1 possible
So I get order nks
subproblems, subproblems.
How much work per
subproblem, just a max
of two things, so constant
work per subproblem
yields order nks time total.
So those are three nice
practice problems for you,
two that are polynomial,
one that's pseudopolynomial.
You have one more
example in there,
which is the Gokemon Po
problem, which is a fun problem.
It involves remembering
additional information that's
not--
not really a pseudopolynomial
number in your problem.
But it's the location of where I
was last, or where I was going.
So take a look at that problem.
It's another kind of non-trivial
way of expanding subproblems.
OK, and with that, good
luck on your quiz 3.